as you probably know we took a page from
uh major league
baseball and we filled our audience with
cardboard cutouts we had fans send in
their photos
we put in cutouts and uh we had a packed
house the last couple of nights maybe
you've seen that
but now it's standing room
only check it out look at this
we we have got i mean the aisles
are clogged the aisles are just jammed
i can't move not just because it's
crowded because that guy's behind me i
don't want it i don't want to give him
an excuse to leap
yeah no no no this strike this is uh
this is
unprecedented i've never seen never seen
in many many years of doing this show
i've never seen
this many people in an audience uh in
fact
we've had some concern from the fire
department it's it's very dangerous
yeah this could be a fire code violation
right now right uh i know that a lot of
you are concerned conan
god forbid there should be a fire in the
theater would you be safe
i want to promise you all i can get out
of here instantly
if i need to even though there are lots
of fans in the aisles
i know how to take care of number one
andy do me a favor just say conan i
smell smoke there could be a fire
conan i smell smoke there could be a
fire
get me out of here get me out of here
i want out get me out
get me out of here i went out
well thanks for tuning in folks uh we'll
be back tomorrow
with more of whatever this is
okay okay that was a worthwhile
exercise i do hope i didn't offend
any of my fans who sent in cutouts and
just saw them crushed
uh on a sincere note i do want to say
that uh these cutouts are helping me
i'm very appreciative that all of you
took the time to send in photos to give
me an audience
really sincerely i thank all of you
except one person that's right
his name is caleb and he's from kansas
city missouri
look at him caleb
thinks he's so much better than me
got so much attitude caleb
who are you to judge me caleb i'm out
here
trying day in day out
whenever i come out on this stage i see
you
judging me same look my father gave me
every day of my life
you're my nemesis caleb
i despise you
it's you or me caleb one of us has to go
there isn't room in this theater for
both of us
technically there is plenty of room
you're
two-dimensional you don't take up much
space but still
i got my eye on you caleb
caleb and i are going to lunch after the
show what are you doing that for
he's a cool guy i like him oh so
suddenly you're caleb's pal
i'm not his pal he just he says lots of
nice stuff about me
and frankly i like it okay
all right fine be friends with caleb i
will